ouais super
star alors tu commences par ici et après
tu pars sur le côté pour viser le milieu
mais si je fais ça ça va marcher
elle a
bien joué en apparence barry 38 ans
ressemble à monsieur tout le monde un
américain moyen qui joue au bowling avec
ses copines
pourtant rosie
rebecca ruby
naomi
allez vas-y lorsque la boule épaules à
la brune ne sont pas ses amis mais ces
cinq femmes
car marie et
polygamie occupe-toi du bébé s'il te
plaît
est-ce que les gens vous regardent
bizarrement que vous êtes tous ensemble
syntaxe parfois houleux mais on les
ignore la plupart du temps ils ne
pensent à rien de spécial la plupart du
temps quand on est ensemble les gens ne
s'imaginent pas qui pourrait avoir cinq
femmes faut être fou
on peut aussi dire qu'on ait une bonne
de secrétaire avec leurs patrouilles
un homme qui vit avec cinq femmes
ouvertement
la scène semble irréel aux états unis et
le plus incroyable c'est qu'ils sont
loin d'être les seuls alors que la
polygamie est illégale en amérique
les polygames habitent principalement
dans l'utah dans l'ouest américain
on estime qu'il serait près de 40000 à
vivre ainsi au nez et à la barbe des
autorités
comme à colorado city et il d'elle deux
villes jumelles ou les 5000 habitants
sont tous polygames
ici on pourrait se croire dans un
épisode de la petite maison dans la
prairie
les polygames vivent comme au 19e siècle
certains se déplacent à cheval
et les femmes s'habillent et se coiffe
comme au temps de la conquête de l'ouest
s'ils vivent ainsi c'est parce qu'ils
appartiennent tous à une secte issus de
l'église mormone très puissante aux
états unis
ils se considèrent comme des
fondamentalistes les seuls à appliquer
aujourd'hui encore les préceptes du père
fondateur de cette religion
joseph smith on le voit ici accompagné
de sa trentaine de femmes
il y a deux siècles il a une révélation
dieu lui explique que pour accéder au
paradis il doit pratiquer la polygamie
et faire beaucoup d'enfants pour étendre
leur religion
les sous la pression de l'état à la fin
du 19e siècle l'église mormone abandonne
officiellement ce mode de vie
certains adeptes refuse qu'ils sont
alors excommunié et partent se cacher
pour fonder des communautés de
dissidents
[Musique]
nous avons voulu savoir comment vivent
ces familles si particulière et pourquoi
leur mode de vie pourtant illégal semble
tolérer
[Musique]
la plupart des polygames habite à la
campagne loin des regards c'est dans ce
hameau que vive baril et ses cinq femmes
le soir quand il rentre à la maison il
n'a pas une minute à lui
allez on va voir maman c'est 23 enfants
lui saute dessus
[Musique]
il y à 14 free et neuf garçons
âgés de 5 mois à 16 ans oui mais
et ce n'est pas une famille recomposée
tous ces enfants barry les a bien eus
avec ses cinq femmes
il y à paul à sa première épouse la
seule à être passés devant le maire et
quatre autres ne sont mariés que
religieusement à bari et sont considérés
par l'administration comme mère
célibataire
ce qui leur permet de toucher des
allocations et de compléter le salaire
de chef d'entreprise de bari
il a épousé ces cinq femmes en l'espace
de huit ans
qui a créé quelques tensions entre elles
quand baril a épousé naomi j'étais
vraiment en colère au début
je savais que ça allait arriver j'étais
contente pour eux mais ce moment ça fait
mal
non
il ya de la jalousie
mais paris est assez doué pour nous
rassurer
[Musique]
au quotidien vivre à 29 demande une
rigueur quasi militaire
pour le dîner les parents préparent les
assiettes des enfants à la chaîne et les
ados font de service
on laisse les enfants manger en premier
et ensuite c'est les adultes qui se
servent et on vient manger dans le salon
et vous ne mangez jamais tous ensemble
autour d'une table vous voulez dire non
pas dans les maisons que nous avons non
et pour éviter les corvées
supplémentaires les assiettes sont en
carton et les couverts en plastique
c'est plus facile ça évite de faire la
vaisselle
le dîner est l'un des rares moments où
toute la famille peut se réunir dans la
journée chaque femme a son propre espace
la famille vit dans deux maisons celle
ci comporte deux appartements celui de
naomi et ses cinq enfants et celui de
rebecca qui a trois enfants
dans la maison d'à côté vive les trois
premières femmes de baril des courses
voici rosie sa troisième femme avec qui
il est marié depuis 17 ans ils ont
ensemble de quatre enfants
on a bien je t'aime
et là on est où là c'est la maison de
rosie
quelques jours la cuisine
là c'est la chambre de rosie est aussi
la mienne enfin à chaque fois que je
suis avec elle
là c'est la chambre des enfants
au bout du couloir au fond de la
buanderie baril a fait aménager un
passage qui mène tout droit chez sa
deuxième femme rubis
[Musique]
salut mon coeur ça va ensemble ils ont
cinq enfants
c'est leur photo l'as
bari est entrepreneur dans le bâtiment
c'est lui qui a construit les maisons et
en bon polygame moderne il a laissé la
finition aux femmes
quand je les ai construite j'ai laissé
les femmes apporter leur contribution
je les ai laissé gérer leur espace donc
toute la déco
il a dit c'est ton espace tu en fais ce
que tu veux ce qu on empruntant cette
porte j'arrive chez paul à
pour éviter les jalousies baril à une
organisation bien rodée il ne dort
jamais deux nuits de suite avec la même
femme
ça change tout les nuits unis avaient
l'appui ruby puis rosine naomi rebecca
et après ça recommence et toutes les
cinq nuits je dors avec voilà que voici
ce soir c'est avec elle qu'il passera la
nuit
je ne connaissais rien à la polygamie
avant l'âge de 17 ans quand mon père à
intégrer une communauté de polygame
et après je me suis converti avec lui le
reste c'est de l'histoire
en apparence c'est presque amusant il
folklorique
mais quant à savoir si ces épouses sont
heureuses c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]
5 femme de barrie ont toutes été élevés
dans des communautés de polygame très
rigoriste toute leur jeunesse jusqu'à ce
qu'elle épouse marie elle était habillée
comme au 19e siècle
on leur a toujours inculqué que la
polygamie permettait d'accéder au
paradis les aujourd'hui toutes les
femmes de bari doute de ses croyances
surtout paul à
je croyais que la polygamie me
permettrait d'aller au paradis
c'est ce que mes parents m'avaient
toujours dit mais maintenant mon point
de vue a changé sur ça
qu'est ce que vous pensez maintenant
[Applaudissements]
pour la noce pas répondre peut-être
parce que barry juste à côté
allez vous en tant que je puisse parler
non je plaisante
et donc je pense qu'on n'est pas obligé
ce n'est pas une obligation
pour regretter
[Musique]
non
c'est dur à vivre
oui bien sûr c'est dur
mais c'est le choix de vie que j'ai fait
à l'époque
un choix de vie fait de frustration et
de concessions et surtout illégal
en rivant ainsi au regard de la loi
barry et ces femmes risquent jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison
mais alors pourquoi les polygames ne
sont ils pas plus inquiété par les
autorités
[Musique]
dans l'utah quasiment tout le monde
connaît ou a eu dans sa famille des
polygames jusque dans les hautes sphères
de l'administration
comme le procureur général de l'état
mark shurtleff son grand-père avait
plusieurs femmes
il reconnaît ouvertement que lutter
contre la polygamie n'est pas pour lui
une priorité et ce pour une raison toute
simple on ne peut pas mettre tout le
monde en prison
willow financièrement on ne peut pas
construire des milliers de places de
prison et mettre des milliers d'enfants
foyer
alors on s'est dit nous n'avons pas les
moyens donc on ne va pas les poursuivre
en revanche si c'est de la polygamie non
consenti si des enfants sont concernés
comme deminor mariée de force là on
enquête et on poursuit en justice
c'est justement ce qui s'est passé il y
a deux ans dans ce ranch au texas où vit
l'une des communautés les plus
extrémistes de polygame
quand la police suspecte des mariages
forcés
elle fait une descente en force et
découvre alors un mode de vie à uris ans
une centaine de femmes mariées à une
quinzaine d'hommes
que l'on voit ici embarqués par la
police
avec leurs 400 enfants
mais le pire c'est que certaines épouses
ne sont que des adolescentes enceintes
déjà maire
douze hommes seront alors inculpé d'abus
sexuels sur mineurs
[Musique]
à la tête de cette communauté un homme
warren jeffs
on lui attribue une centaine de femmes
certaines extrêmement jeune sur cette
photo on le voit avec l'une de ses
dernières épouse elle aurait à peine 14
ans
[Musique]
dans sa communauté qui représente près
de 10000 polygame il est considéré comme
le prophète
sur ordre de dieu comme il dit warren
jeffs forcé des adolescentes à épouser
des hommes beaucoup plus vieux avant
d'être arrêté par le fbi haye il vivait
à colorado city où tous les habitants de
la ville sont membres de sa communauté
sam brewers le traquaient depuis
plusieurs années ce détective privé a
longtemps enquêté sur les dérives du
prophète pour le compte d'anciennes
victimes
il vivait là où marine chef
derrière ces murs tout le quartier est à
lui il ya plusieurs grandes maisons
certaines de ces femmes vivent encore
ici
une enquête difficile car la ville est
surveillé 24 heures sur 24 par ses
habitants
on dirait qu'on est suivi par la
camionnette derrière là
effectivement plusieurs voitures vont se
relayer pour nous suivre et nous faire
comprendre que nous ne sommes pas les
bienvenus
ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
nous mettre mal à l'aise ils n'aiment
pas les étrangers par ici il n'aime pas
que les gens viennent dans leur ville
quelques mètres plus loin au détour d'un
virage un homme nous prend même en photo
malgré cette surveillance constante sam
a pu réunir des preuves accablantes sur
warren jeffs comme les discours qu'il a
réussi à enregistrer à l'insu du gourou
s'il arrive quelque chose à cet
ordinateur ce serait tragique
les commandements qui montre à quel
point le prophète manipule sa communauté
par la peur
un lavage de cerveau qui maintient la
communauté sous contrôle
et pour celles qui voudraient s'enfuir
en refusant le marais qu'il leur a
choisi warren jeffs a tout prévu
les policiers sont des employés de la
ville mais en fait ils sont sous les
ordres du prophète
si par exemple une jeune fille va voir
la police car elle ne veut pas se marier
ils vont simplement la renvoyer vers les
membres influents de la communauté au
lieu de la protéger
reste alors une seule solution
s'enfuir sans se retourner
après des années de souffrance elissa 23
ans a eu le courage de partir et de
porter plainte contre celui qu'elle
considérait jusque là comme son prophète
dans son armoire elle garde un souvenir
douloureux sa robe de mariage
quand je me suis regardé dans le miroir
avec cette robe j'avais l'impression de
me préparer à mes funérailles plutôt
qu'à mon mariage
alors qu'elle n'a que 14 ans elle est
mariée de force à son propre cousin de
19 ans c'est warren jeffs qu'il l'a
décrété du jour au lendemain
la cérémonie a été pratiquée en secret
parce que j'étais très jeune j'étais en
dessous de l'âge légal du mariage mais
il s'en fiche parce que là bas les
femmes sont considérées comme des
propriétés et une fois que vous êtes
mariée à un homme il devient votre dieu
c'est lui qui décide de tout dans votre
vie vous devez vous soumettre et être
une femme parfaite
elissa n'avait aucun accès au monde
extérieur
pas de télévision pas de journaux une
éducation rudimentaire basée sur la
religion
après quatre ans de mariage forcé
elle s'enfuit et découvre un monde
totalement nouveau
là bas on n'a pas le droit de se
maquiller il considère ça comme un signe
du diable
on n'a pas le droit de se couper les
cheveux non plus
elissa aurais tu aimé que sa mère
s'oppose au mariage
qu'elle l'aide à s'enfuir mais elle n'a
rien fait pour l'aider
[Musique]
en tant que maire dans l'environnement
auquel elle appartenait elle n'avait
aucun moyen d'arrêter ce qui arrive est
à sa fille même si elle me voyait aller
vers l'enfer
aujourd'hui la jeune femme s'est fait
une promesse
elle s'est juré que ses enfants seront
libres de choisir leur ville